retour en 1661
Louis XIV parvient difficilement à
cacher sa passion pour sa nouvelle
conquête Louise de lavallière
à tel point que sa mère Anne d'Autriche
pieuse et dévote sagace de ce
comportement qu'elle juge libertin
si elle pour que mon fils se comporte de
la
obsession pour les femmes je ne la
supporte plus
[Musique]
Louis XIV n'écoutera pas sa mère quoi
qu'elle pense il la décidait Louise de
lavallière fait désormais partie de sa
vie mais il manque encore quelque chose
au roi pour assouvir sa soif de grandeur
et de pouvoir un château à la mesure de
ses ambitions et dans lequel il pourra
vivre comme bon lui semble et ce château
ce sera Versailles à cette époque le
bâtiment ressemble encore à cela un
petit pavillon de chasse perdu au milieu
des marais mais Louis XIV veut
transformer ce bâtiment pour en faire le
plus grand et le plus beau château
jamais construit alors pendant 50 ans
plusieurs milliers d'hommes vont
travailler sur ce chantier titanesque
[Musique]
je crois que Louis XIV a passé sa vie à
vouloir laisser une trace avec les
enfants qu'il faisait successivement les
quantités d'enfants c'est une trace sont
des traces qui laissent avec le pouvoir
qu'il prend les guerres qu'il fait les
frontières qu'il a grandi et avec le
château de Versailles qu'il va
construire et qu'il voulait comme étant
le plus beau château de la chrétienté
Louis XIV a une idée très précise du
château qu'il souhaite alors il
surveille les travaux lui-même jusque
dans les moindres détails
Louis XIV multiplié les visites de
chantier et il contrôlaient tout des
grands plafonds jusque au dessin des
jardins et jusqu'à l'entourage parfois
d'une même d'une serrure
[Musique]
on a une lettre très belle de Colbert à
Louis XIV Colbert l'informe de
l'avancement des travaux dans le château
de Versailles il lui dit jusqu'où je
dois vous mettre au courant pour ne pas
vous ennuyer c'est un peu comme
aujourd'hui est-ce que je vous mets en
copie du mail de tous les mails
50000 m² de plancher plus de 2000
fenêtres 700 pièces 67 escaliers 800
hectares de parc 20 km de route 200 000
arbres un château digne des plus grands
empereurs de l'Antiquité
[Musique]
il fallait en mettre plein la vue Louis
XIV c'est quelqu'un qui veut éblouir le
Roi Soleil son nom il le porte bien mais
il veut éblouir et c'est pour ça que
avec les femmes il veut que ce soit
toujours de très jolies femmes des
femmes éblouissantes
[Musique]
et puis la cerise sur le château et sans
nul doute la
sellerie des glaces connues dans le
monde entier elle sera achevée
tardivement en 1684 une pièce
gigantesque de 73 mètres de long 10
mètres de large 12 mètres de haut qui
comporte 357 miroirs 17 fenêtres et 20
lustres une salle splendide symbole de
la grandeur de Louis XIV
[Musique]